[Music]
marketing automation to me is
particularly exciting marketing
automation automates those little things
that you should be doing regularly and
probably have already done at one time
or another it enables you to find new
customers faster on board existing
customers increased loyalty among your
existing customers and then also
identify your high-growth and highly
profitable customer segments and
increase your communication and your
engagement with them as a simple
definition marketing automation is about
using software and technology to perform
sales and marketing functions more
effectively through using multiple
channels and it automates simple tasks
that might sound like a mouthful but
let's divide that up the first thing is
by automating simple repetitive messages
that you've probably already written you
can explode your engagement among
prospects existing customers and
onboarding new customers for example a
new customer to your business they may
not know everything about you and all
the aspects of the products for services
that you have so with a welcome series
where you time specific messages to them
to familiarize your new customer about
your company what you offer and focus on
educating them well they're your newest
customers you're going to engage them
for a longer period of time you're going
to drive some immediate responses and
they're going to become familiar with
you your company and your brand see when
people receive a welcome series of
emails that
form and educate them about your company
welcome series emails are opened more
frequently they're clicked through more
frequently and they drive more revenue
than any other type of email by taking
communications that you've most likely
already written it's a matter of putting
them on a schedule but they're only
going to be sent to new customers at
specific intervals you can plan these
communications to elicit a response
utilize links in those emails to drive
those new customers back to your site to
learn more information about your
company or provide a specific call to
action anytime anyone takes an action
and interacts with your website or with
your company you can also send them a
thank-you email a thank you email gets
much more engagement than the other type
of email people open and click through
at a higher rate than typical email
campaigns but what's interesting is just
by sending a thank-you email it can also
generate six times the revenue of other
types of email campaigns as well
people like to be recognized and noticed
for the things they do and when you do
that through interactions with your
company you increase your customer
loyalty the second most exciting thing
about marketing automation is the
ability to flatten your sales funnel and
by that I mean you can reduce the amount
of time of taking someone from a lead to
a prospect to a sale decrease the amount
of time it takes for someone who has
interest in your company until they're a
customer because through coordinating
planned communications you walk them
through the steps of giving them the
answers to the questions that they have
because you probably already have these
emails your sales team may already have
written these emails but by identifying
the typical questions prospects have
before they become customers the typical
obstacles that are encountered you can
create planned communications that go
out on a schedule and lead people
through the
process and by doing that you're
automating information through a series
that helps to prioritize then who you
should contact first which prospects you
can spend more time you can learn if
these are good leads or just someone who
is just looking for some information and
they don't have any intention of
becoming a customer through these
planned communications you can see who
is interacting with your company who has
expressed needs that you can act on and
that brings me to the third point by
flattening the sales funnel you're going
to close more deals and you close more
deals because you have the ability
through marketing automation to focus on
the right leads at the right time let me
give you a couple of examples and maybe
some of this has happened to you
the first scenario I downloaded a white
paper that was promoted on Twitter I
followed the link filled out the form
and downloaded the white paper but what
was interesting as I received a sales
call the same day and then I received
two more sales calls trying to close me
in two weeks now what's the problem with
that it was too much sales too much
pressure and all I did was download a
white paper they never even asked if I
got anything out of the white paper they
just treated me as a lead in the funnel
now let's look at the next scenario the
next scenario is I received an email and
it was a sponsored email from someone
that I already trusted and they pitched
a white paper well I went ahead and
downloaded that white paper and then
over the course of the next four months
I received invitations to download
additional white papers to attend
webinars helpful information about that
content and got a few emails that just
walked me along the process of what this
company can do and also highlighted some
success stories after those four months
I received a phone call it was
incredible
they knew the content that I had looked
at they knew which webinars
I attended and we had a good
conversation because it wasn't high
pressure they knew exactly the content I
was interested in and they were using
the phone call to gauge my urgency was I
ready to buy what was my time line and
so it was an intelligent conversation
about specific content what I found
valuable and really just gauging my
interest level see the result of that
type of scenario is that is going to
result in a high conversion qualified
sales call that has actionable results
marketing automation does require some
patience but it will limit the amount of
time you spend with leads that don't
exhibit any behavior of interest or
desire to become a customer and so
marketing automation enables you to
close the prospect more efficiently more
knowledgeably because you have a shared
experience shared content and you can
approach a phone call or a closing
conversation with specific information
about that prospect and you can use that
phone call simply to gather more data
rather than to apply pressure to make a
decision
a course of all these things happen
you're going to make more money but
you're going to make more money also by
evaluating your existing customers
through marketing automation you see
through marketing automation we can
nurture leads to become customers we can
nurture our existing customer base to
learn more information about them as we
learn where our customers live their
likes their dislikes their preferences
the content they find interesting the
products that they are more attracted to
then we can start conversing with them
on a more personable a more specific
level we can develop highly efficient
customer segments from the data that
we've accumulated and we could present
offers that are highly targeted relevant
and specific to each group of customers
the fifth reason why I absolutely love
marketing automation is that it helps me
identify my best customers I love going
through and looking for my top 20% of
customers and figuring out why are they
my top 20% and then I can build better
loyalty by giving better offers that are
more customized and personalized to them
and then I can develop an inner circle
mentality I can provide incentives I can
talk to them at a different level
because these are the ones that are most
likely going to be my advocates and so I
can feed them information I can treat
them differently because they're on a
different level than the rest of my
customers and automation helps me
identify these customers faster more
efficiently and deliver information that
they want to hear
that's the overview of marketing
automation I hope it's excited you to
take the first steps necessary in order
to implement this in your organization
I'm Matt Bailey marketing automation
chair here at market modem Hey once you
become an expert in digital marketing
then subscribe to the simply learned
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn up and get certified in
digital marketing click here